It is lovely to be with you
here this evening.
So as you just heard,
my name is Katherine Maher
and I used to be, until very recently,
the CEO of the Wikimedia Foundation,
which is the organization
behind Wikipedia.
And my tenure coincided
with a very strange time for information.
A global crisis of fake news
and disinformation,
which meant that our
free-knowledge movement
really sort of stood alone.
At the same time, too,
we saw a collapse
in public trust around the world
in many of our
critical civic institutions.
And one of the reasons
for this collapse in public trust,
in things like public science
and an independent free press
and even perhaps in the idea
of democracy itself,
is that people around the globe
are increasingly skeptical
about the ability of these institutions
to respond to our future challenges
and changing needs.
And yet, during this time,
trust in Wikipedia actually went up.
Something that surprised us
as much as anyone.
And so I started wondering,
what is it about this organization,
this radical experiment in openness,
self-governance
and amateurism, volunteerism,
that made it so different?
And I've come to believe
that in many ways,
the things that made Wikipedia implausible
are actually what prepare it
to respond to our changing world.
And make it a place
that people love and trust.
And so one of the
things about it, of course,
is that it is edited entirely
by volunteers,
ordinary people from all over the world.
All of the decisions
about encyclopedic content
and organizational policies
take place in a transparent
and open fashion.
This means that Wikipedia
can continue to change
as the world changes around it,
integrating new ideas
and new perspectives.
But I think one
of the most critical things
that I found really important
is that its model pushes us
to work together
into deliberation and into conversation
so that the end result is something
that most of us feel
is reasonable and fair.
Now, easy enough for some things,
like articles on animals
with fraudulent diplomas ...
(Laughter)
Which is a real article on Wikipedia.
But what about the hard things,
the places where we are prone
to disagreement,
say, politics and religion?
Well, as it turns out,
not only does Wikipedia's
model work there,
it actually works really well.
Because in our normal lives,
these contentious
conversations tend to erupt
over a disagreement
about what the truth actually is.
But the people who write these articles,
they're not focused on the truth.
They're focused on something else,
which is the best
of what we can know right now.
And after seven years of working
with these brilliant folks,
I've come to believe
that they are onto something.
That perhaps for our most
tricky disagreements,
seeking the truth
and seeking to convince
others of the truth
might not be the right place to start.
In fact,
our reverence for the truth
might be a distraction
that's getting in the way
of finding common ground
and getting things done.
Now,
that is not to say
that the truth doesn't exist,
nor is it to say
that the truth isn’t important.
Clearly, the search for the truth
has led us to do great things,
to learn great things.
But ...
I think if I were to really ask you
to think about this,
one of the things
that we could all acknowledge
is that part of the reason
we have such glorious chronicles
to the human experience
and all forms of culture
is because we acknowledge
there are many different truths.
And so in the spirit of that,
I'm certain that the truth exists for you
and probably for the person
sitting next to you.
But this may not be the same truth.
This is because the truth of the matter
is very often, for many people,
what happens when we merge
facts about the world
with our beliefs about the world.
So we all have different truths.
They're based on things
like where we come from,
how we were raised
and how other people perceive us.
Now you and your neighbor,
who's probably a reasonable person --
they look like a nice person?
Yeah, they're probably
a reasonable person.
(Laughs)
You two can probably get together
and come to some sort of shared agreement.
But what happens when a third person
joins the conversation
or a fourth or a fifth?
What happens when we try
to expand this out
to the scale of all 7.8 billion of us?
The reality is we are a vast
and varied world.
And so when we try to use
our personal truths
to come to conversations
around collective decision-making
on important issues,
we start to run into problems.
Because collective decision-making,
the sort of thing that we want to do
in democratic and open societies
requires that we get together
with common understandings
about the root of the problem
and some assumptions
about how we might get out of it.
But if we're using
our personal truths to do this,
we end up having conversations
about our values and our identity.
Because remember, our truths
come from where we come from.
And then we're focusing on what divides us
instead of what we can agree upon.
And that allows us to start having
conversations about the truth
in a way that focuses on what we believe
rather than what can be known.
And that is a definition
that is deeply divisive and harmful.
I think about our lack
of urgent action on climate change.
We've known for a very long time now
about the negative impacts
of man-made carbon in the atmosphere.
But ...
[the] implications of that data
challenge our identities,
our industries, our communities
in ways that have led and created
resistance and even disinformation,
and the resulting public debates
about the truth of climate change
have prevented us from taking specific
and concrete actions
that could mitigate the harms
to us around rising seas,
increasingly deadly waves of heat and cold
and powerful storm systems.
With such urgent threats ahead of us,
we need better ways
to get to a shared understanding.
Fortunately, I've seen how, at Wikipedia,
we can come to cooperative
and productive conversations
around disagreement and decision making
without using one shared truth
as our baseline.
Its generous and accommodating approach
offers us a practical way
to take it down a notch,
focusing on something
a little less stressful:
the best of what can be known right now.
And the good news is
we can know a lot of things.
We have high-quality information,
facts and data that allow us to do things
like track the migration
of endangered species
or the spread of a pandemic
around the world.
These are useful tools in our toolbox,
but they don't necessarily
alone change minds
or unite disparate views.
So how do we do that?
We shift from focusing on one key truth
to instead finding minimum viable truth.
Minimum viable truth means
getting it right enough
enough of the time
to be useful enough to enough people.
It means setting aside
our bigger belief systems
and not being quite so fussy
about perfection.
And this idea of minimum viable truth
is actually a tremendously forgiving idea,
which is one of the things
I love about it the most.
It recognizes our messy humanity.
It acknowledges space for uncertainty,
for bias and for disagreement
on our way to the search for the answers.
So ...
one thing you may not know about Wikipedia
is that it actually assumes
that we are all biased.
It is the reason that you are not supposed
to write articles about yourselves.
Because can any of you truly be neutral
about how brilliant
and remarkable you are?
(Laughter)
I didn't think so.
But when we are forced
to defend our biases,
when we are forced to go
into the data and the citations
and really engage,
grapple with the intellectual struggle
that comes from meeting up
against other people's biases,
our horizons can expand
and we can get to new and better
understandings about the world.
How does this work?
Well, in 2019,
a group of researchers released a study
looking at how Wikipedia writers
take on the most contentious
and difficult topics.
And what they found
was that the system
actually works really well.
These are some of the best
articles on Wikipedia.
And many of them are written by people
who fundamentally disagree
with one another.
They also found something interesting,
which is that the more
that these polarized contributors
engaged in conversation,
the more balanced and productive
their contributions became.
Which means that Wikipedia may be
one of the only places on the internet
where disagreement actually
makes you more agreeable.
Now, I knew instinctively this is true
because I’ve seen how productive friction
can really get us places,
how mistakes and debate actually
brings people into the conversation.
You don’t sit back
when you disagree with someone,
because engaging offers you the chance
to shape the public record.
Through that process,
ideas become sharper, better
and more understandable
In this way, the seeds of our disagreement
can actually become the roots
of our common purpose.
All of this is very well and good,
but what does it mean
and how do we actually apply it
to other organizations and institutions
and systems that we are a part of,
in order to increase trust
and reduce polarization
and perhaps get
some important things done?
Well, I've already talked a little bit
about productive friction,
the good kind that makes our ideas better.
That is possible because of a few things:
notably, clear rules
and strong community norms.
Clear rules help us engage
on the substance of the issue
rather than debating
the identity of the author.
Those rules are not upheld
by any one individual on high.
They're actually maintained and uplifted
by the entire community.
So we all have a shared sense
of responsibility for success.
The other piece of this is
that it is essential
that decisions are not just made
by those who show up in the room.
You have to be intentional
about bringing all the voices in.
When Wikipedia first started,
the majority of its authors
were Western white men,
which led to some really
significant biases and gaps
in the types of articles that were written
and the slant of those articles.
Recognizing this by being intentional
about undoing some of these systems
that were actively excluding people
and doing the hard work
of actually rebuilding them
so that more people would feel
welcome in the conversation,
we are now able to have
a better reflection of the known world.
The next piece of this is really
about interdependence.
The way that the system works
is that you cannot go it alone.
In order for your contributions to stick,
they have to earn the agreement
of your fellow contributors,
which is a powerful forcing mechanism
for people to work together.
Next is the idea of shared power.
All of those debates result
in 350 edits a minute to Wikipedia,
which means that no one person
can be in charge of the whole thing.
You have to let go of power.
You have to give it to other people.
You have to trust in their ability
to manage the areas
of their own expertise and interests.
And by doing so,
you earn their commitment and agency
to make this project work.
It also requires humility
because you're going to get it wrong
some of the times.
But getting it wrong some of the time
is worth it for getting it right
most of the time.
And speaking of time,
you have to have a very different
relationship to urgency.
So much in the world is about moving fast.
But moving fast has actually
broken a lot of things.
It's broken our trust.
It has undermined our confidence
in many of our systems of governance,
perhaps even our faith
in democracy itself.
By slowing down a little bit
and bringing the conversation in,
by listening with sincerity,
debating with respect,
consulting widely
and weighing difficult
decisions with candor,
you can actually build
systems that endure.
But most importantly, you can build trust,
that quality that is in such
short supply right now.
And trust in one another is what we need
in order to weather uncertainty
and take brave action.
So what I'm asking all of you today
is to set aside your own
personal truth for just a minute,
for the opportunity
to sit in someone else's.
It's to endure the productive friction
of coming to common agreement
with someone who you may not agree with
or perhaps even like.
And with just enough rules
and a little bit of time,
I believe that you can do it.
And you just might find,
we all just might find,
that the most important things that we do
are the ones that we do together.
Thank you.
(Applause)